michael cohen is going down Bigley we've
now learned that it wasn't just private
companies hiring Trump's personal
attorney Michael Cohen to help them out
to advise them but Ukraine paid Michael
Cohen to arrange talks with Donald
Trump's White House as a reminder we
know that Michael Cohen was paid 600
thousand bucks by AT&T 1.2 million
dollars by pharmaceutical company
Novartis a Russian oligarch gave him
five hundred thousand dollars more than
four million dollars dollars in total
ran through a particular bank account
that's been identified it's bad enough
that Cohen was selling influence on
Trump to companies but we've now learned
that Michael Cohen was secretly paid at
least four hundred thousand dollars to
set up talks between the Ukrainian
president and Donald Trump this has been
confirmed by sources in Kiev Ukraine and
this is now brazen criminality right
this is no longer corporate lobbying
which is bad enough its geopolitical
quid pro quo Michael Cohen is not a
registered he's not a registered agent
he's not a registered representative of
Ukraine which he is required to be by US
law and this is the kicker ukrainian
President Petro poroshenko met with
Donald Trump in other words Cohen was
allegedly paid four hundred thousand to
set up a meeting between the Ukrainian
president and Trump and they met in June
of 2017 and of course Michael Cohen is
denying the entire thing despite the
very very good sourcing that we're
seeing on the story and even the
explanation as to why Cohen was brought
in to help Ukraine makes a lot of sense
Ukraine has real lobbyists in DC they
were only going to be able to get sort
of like a brief photo op with Trump for
the Ukrainian president and Ukraine
wanted it to seem like there were real
talks going on to sort of bolster
poroshenko's street cred for lack of a
better term also because poroshenko was
concerned about Paul Manafort working
with anti Ukrainian forces within
Ukraine and knowing that that's
connected to Donald Trump so there were
real reasons for poroshenko to want to
meet with Donald Trump in more than a
photo op the only question we have
is how much was Cohen paid because
there's one report that says 400,000
there's another source that says it was
really 600,000 and it was corruption by
Michael Cohen to try to counteract Paul
manna for its corruption effectively no
one is currently alleging that Trump
knew anything about the payment when he
met with the Ukrainian president but
seriously trumpets if it turned out that
I don't know John Podesta or Hillary's
friends Sidney Blumenthal or someone
like that was making millions of dollars
selling influence to Hillary Clinton our
influence on Hillary Clinton or access
to Hillary Clinton would anybody be
saying nothing to see here because
Hillary didn't know about the money that
was being funneled to Sidney Blumenthal
her to John Podesta it'd be 24/7
hysteria on right-wing media and we
should be prepared for the next
goalposts move right the next goalposts
move is going to be why should Trump and
his cronies go to prison for their
corruption Hillary Clinton never went to
prison for her corruption Barack Obama
never went to prison for his corruption
so why do we even care about this
corruption with Trump and his cronies
and as far as Michael Cohen and all the
money that he took this means we have to
look at every deal he made to see what
came of it and what I mean is
Novartis for example they said okay we
paid him 1.2 million but at our first
meeting with Cohen we realized he wasn't
gonna be able to deliver what it was we
hired him to do Cohen delivered what
Ukraine wanted right the quid pro quo
was completed it bore fruit so to speak
this means that it's quite likely that
some of those other deals some of those
other corrupt acts consulting deals as
they call them also bore fruit and I
know that the term Watergate has been
thrown around quite a bit related to
Trump and I've been hesitant to really
make the comparison there is a very long
list of possible crimes here right Cohen
not registering as a foreign agent as I
mentioned that would be a crime if he
lied to the feds about any of this stuff
possibly that would be a crime that's
the same crime Michael Flynn was
ultimately indicted for not knowing law
does not make you immune from them if
Cohen made any attempt to hide or shield
the money that would show intent to
defraud whether there was actual tax
fraud or money laundering on the receipt
of this money and whether that money was
actually on the record that's another
possible area of criminality so we now
have potentially bribery weapons deals
obstruction conspiracy to defraud and
attempt to cover up isn't this clearly
bigger than Watergate now and that's
exactly what I want to talk about next
because it's actually a growing topic of
discussion the video you just watched
was made possible by support from you
please go to patreon.com slash david
pakman show you can make a pledge of as
little as $1 per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad